[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we're gonna figure out is
Australia the greatest place on earth
oh and why are we qualified to explore
this question well because we went in
there we spent it a little over two
weeks there well I think it was a little
under two weeks we spent a little under
two weeks there so that's two guys who
spent a little under two weeks there we
know enough to come to a definitive
conclusion as to whether or not
Australia is the greatest place on earth
we we've got a lot to fill you in on
because yeah we are fresh off of a
record-breaking length of vacation we
have never in the history of our lives
well I don't know about you but I know
for certain I've never been on a
three-week vacation and I mean when you
tack on the fact that we also went to
Fiji I braggin I'm just stating we went
to Fiji after going or Fiji Fiji as they
say in Australia not exactly how you say
it it's really hard to like get there
the rhythm of how they say Fiji they
also but no no Fiji in Fiji I'll talk
about the way Australian people say Fiji
oh yeah you're right they say Fiji Fiji
but that's still not doing it right
longest vacation we've ever had and we
were we were both there for it yeah well
with our families in tow we've only ever
done like a week at a time and because
we were able to make this a little bit
of a work thing with the tour stops we
were able to kind of justify it
we're like when are we gonna be in this
part of the world another time we're
gonna be flying back over the South
Pacific over all these beautiful islands
well you got a stop in Fiji gotta stop
somewhere I mean you gotta get gas
actually you don't have to you can fly
direct there but we flew directly there
but you can't fly directly back when
Fiji is in the way right you got to stop
and so we did of course we do
want to but we had to and it was a bit
of an experiment bringing everybody
along we'll talk about the ins and the
outs of having you know an is actually a
ten person group because we took our
families but we also took our assistant
general with us and there was a lot of
calculation that went into I mean the
planning I'm not even just talking about
the tour component I'm just talking
about saying okay over over a year ago
it could have been like a year and a
half ago we were talking about okay not
this summer but next summer we're gonna
take a long vacation
I remember we started to have those
conversations because you got to start
protecting calendar time so it doesn't
get eaten up us stuff the past two
summers were dedicated to shooting
filming buddy system so we knew we
wanted to take some family times and
then once we had the the experience of
the tour mythicality and you know there
was a groundswell of mythical beasts
asking us to bring it down to the under
hmmm like how you had already said down
so you wanted to not say down under
again I like that was a good recovery
thank you
bring it down to the under that should
be well I learn that from them that's
how they talk about it well it should be
like a slogan for some sort of
Australian business that we should open
it or just the tourism department bring
it down to the under I'm not gonna try
to use an accent because my favorite
people on earth now yep so this trip was
a culmination of over a year of planning
and then of course we got into doing the
tour dates so let's just take a second
and say thank you to all of you mythical
beasts down there in the under who came
out to our shows Melbourne Sydney
Brisbane I gotta say it was I thought
they called Brisbane Brizzy and they
call breakfast brekkie they they have
like a cute way of like saying things
well they shorten things in general even
though those technically are they
shorten them in a happy way right you
know like oh you went to Brizzy you went
up - Brizzy it's like yeah it was it was
great you know what
about it but that's just how they talk
in a happy shortened way so we're gonna
talk all about our experience but we do
want to talk about the mythical beast
who came out to the shows on the tour of
mythicality because you never know what
to expect I mean having traveled around
the u.s. doing the show we always had
great crowds some you know there's a
combination of that particular group of
people and the venue that you're in and
also how we're doing as performers that
kind of creates this unknown response
that you're gonna get in the moment and
you never know if this if you're gonna
be like this is an incredible super
lively crowd that stayed engaged all
they got that joke and they got that
joke and they were there all the way to
the end when it gets really weird I
gotta say the Australian crowd was as I
mean this is part of this is one data
point this is one point and the whole
argument that we might be making that
Australia's the greatest place on earth
that we might be talking about at least
amongst the best mythical beasts in the
world live there I mean they're all I'm
not gonna say they got a great sense of
humor but I will say that they seem to
find us funny
we felt completely at home and listen
we've been told that that the way that
we think about things or our style of
humor appeals to the certain pockets in
the world outside of the US and we had
heard that Australia was one of those
places but we did not really anticipate
the the level of connection that there
would be the funny thing that we heard
multiple times that I could never have
expected we have the meet and greet
after each of the three shows and people
would say again and again I love your
accents you sound so American and we're
like well don't you listen don't you
listen and watch us like a lot and they
would say things like yeah but it's it's
it's so much more pronounced in person
that's what I would say and we've never
been on the receiving end of that but as
Americans who have not tried we haven't
travelled extensively
we traveled around the u.s. pretty
extensively but not the world very
extensively and there's a lot of people
from a lot of different places that come
to America and you know the old adage
that if you've got a different accent
that you're immediately interesting and
appealing to Americans yo yeah but I
didn't know if it worked in Reverse but
it's the the response was it was
interesting it's like oh it you know the
way I would think it would have been
like it sounds boring I roll yeah it's
it seems boring and like it seems like a
newscaster from Oklahoma it's kind of
where we sort of landed in terms of the
way that we speak but I do think when we
were when we interact on an
interpersonal level I guess I I realized
that we that our accents come out more
when we're not in like a performance
mode like when we're not on the show or
something you know it's just we would
really let our hair down I'm just being
really get just real loose with so nice
to meet y'all you're just such a good
good
audience that's how we talk let's take a
picture let's take a picture together
anyway thank you all no sounded creepy
for coming out we actually we met a lot
of mythical beasts we met a lot of
mythical beasts who didn't even know
that we were there to do a show so we
learned our lesson on at the show on the
street we might need to do better job at
advertising we're gonna be a place but
we're gonna be at other places in the
future so go to two of mythicality calm
if you want to see us in Toronto Jersey
yeah and and those shows more spot those
shows were up for four months ahead of
time so just just remember just check
check that site you know let's get it to
just our overarching impressions of the
continent of Australia I think that you
know there's this there's a stereotype
that the people are nice but I'll say
for for a continent that was colonized
by prisoners go it's a really nice place
I mean that's quite a strange
juxtaposition you know that I mean
they're not there's there's not they're
not like in shackles anymore but also we
learn quite a bit about the history it's
petty
petty crimes and apparently people who
commit petty crimes you know short of
murder and like stealing horses and
stuff like that
small small crimes cuz stuff like that
they would just kill you apparently
execute you as the word I should yeah
apparently if you if your ancestors
committed petty crimes you're more
likely to be just a generally nice and
you know easygoing person well they
would so the moral of the story is we
should begin committing petty crimes now
so that generations down the line the
you know the great-grandchildren will be
will be easygoing people right no oh I'm
not gonna respond to that all I'm gonna
say
the P it was just the the people were
indeed nice I didn't meet anyone who was
currently a prisoner at least they
didn't tell me that and we were in and
we were in cities I mean the you know
there's 24 million people in Australia
the majority of those people live in the
major cities because there's not a whole
lot of people that are like living in
the middle of the outback of course they
kind of live on the coast but you know
you've got like almost 10 million people
just between Melbourne and Sydney so
you're getting almost half the country
there and people in cities that big tend
to be at least in America like once
you'd get into a place that is really
large and becomes impersonal and you
don't really know that your neighbor and
you don't know the people that you're
walking past on the street people just
kind of become a-holes
and it's just a part of the culture I
mean that's the way it is in Los Angeles
but there just really was this Pleasant
interaction with people at all levels of
interaction like somebody at a
restaurant or somebody that was you know
driving you around or whatever well and
the thing that we read was that there's
a cliche that they think Americans are
too loud yeah so I was cut I was
self-conscious about speaking loud
because I think I was like well they're
probably correct and then a great test
of that at least how different they
perceive conversational volume
we do is on the television oh gosh
Australian television went so when I was
in the the hotel room I just turned on
the TV I was like I'm gonna flip around
this Australian TV and yeah a little bit
at a shtetl cultural orientation yeah
come to the down come down to the under
and see what's on the TV does it work in
that context that work yeah that was
great
and first things first game shows there
were like four game shows on the like 25
available channels and but the game
shows were I gotta say anti exciting I'm
not gonna use the term boring because
this is the greatest placeholder but the
most understated every everything about
them was understated the way the host
would just to talk about this volume
right here but then there was a game
where they were just doing math or maths
as they say like literally they had like
a whiteboard and there would be a couple
of numbers and then you'd have to do on
your whiteboard like how do you get from
this number to this number and then they
would turn it around and show their math
like they're in school and that they got
it right the audience would be like good
maths but they wouldn't have been a good
maths good maths
I mean gotta take a commercial break now
but when we come back we're gonna have
more math and then I turn to yes I guess
it was ESPN or their equivalent of ESPN
it was a sports channel and they were
talking about footy which I learned all
about and and fascinated by a lot like
rugby but different Australian rules
football and they were analyzing it but
so just for a perspective in the u.s.
the way that all the sports channels and
all the sports shows have gone is now
you've got to have a strong opinion in
fact like half of the shows on ESPN are
based on the premise that there's two
guys and they're arguing against each
other they don't even believe it it's
just they know they got to conjure up
some sort of yeah you have to disagree
sharp a pin you have to have a strong
opinion and you have to defend it well
it was just three guys sitting around
talking about like this and they were
just all agreeing with each other you
know you think you had a good point
about that it's pleasant man it's just
they're all so pleasant I got a mitt I
didn't continue watching because I feel
like my sensitivities are my
sensibilities have been tuned to people
just nearly killing each other about
every single possible issue that's the
way we handle things in America so to
see people just pleasantly discuss
things it's boring to me but maybe I
could adapt um something that was weird
I don't mean to complain because this is
not a complaint it's just it's just an
observation I had I hit a speed bump
trying to figure this out but every
receptacle I'm talking about a plug like
an outlet yeah she plug your stuff into
of course we had to bring adapters
because their plugs are all wonky
well maybe ours her wonky ever thought
about that there's a wonky they go
sideways
they like their wonky they go like this
like and by the circus there are four
entries yeah
the two top slots a little walking but
above everything where you can plug
something in there's a switch you notice
that yeah you can talked about it you
could turn the outlet on and off which
is which is tough when you're like
you're plugging in your adapter and then
you're plugging in your phone charger
and then you're plugging in your phone
and then well after I've done all that
you got to remember to also flick on the
switch above the outlet every I didn't
see it must have been like a a law or
some point it's part of the code it's
part of their code you got to turn on
the receptacle after you've plugged into
it I think has something to do with
being descended from petty criminals
well let's say think about let's think
about yes it's it's safety so that it's
probably so a kid just can't think it's
like a keyhole yeah but what if the kid
just flips it on and then thinks it's a
keyhole well then that kid deserves
ultimately I think the American kids
deserve it if they put a key in but
Australian kids only deserve it if
they're smart enough to then flip the
switch to I think it is a superior
system and I'm not just saying that
because I want to build the argument for
Australia being the greatest place on
earth I think is a superior system
because if you have a device that is on
wind plugged in and doesn't have a power
switch like I don't know there's got to
be one out there then maybe if you want
to leave it plugged in hairdryer that's
malfunctioning well you know how like
when you've got something plugged in
here like I know that there's power like
going into it right now and there's some
switch on it that's keeping the power
from going this is how electricity works
it's like a there's a hose of electrons
they're just pushing their way into that
hairdryer and they're on the tip and the
hairdryer there's the tip gotta switch
to keep on them and they're building up
in that hairdryer about to explode hey
hair job getting blue by I want all that
electricity pressure to build up in the
wall not on my device right cuz then we
doesn't clearly what it is I it's cuz
then when you unplug it either way
you've still got a hairdryer full of
electrons thing about you unplugging
this is like they go somewhere right
well it that happens either way man it's
not better in Australia
you cut office days in the wall oh
you're saying you cut once you're done
with the hairdryer you leave the
hairdryer on but you turn it off at the
wall so it drains all of its power
they're probably making like a garden
hose they're probably saving cents on
the dollar because of this technology do
you leave water in your garden hose
outside of your house here in America
yeah so it'll heat up and be like a warm
bath the next time I got it on yeah well
you're talking about both sides you
mouth now well that's water not
electricity totally different thing and
the two shall not mix well I'm sorry I
sent herself on that tangent you did you
also notice that in public places like
airports and restaurants I mostly wear
our gets firmer hold on let me say full
of electronic airports and hotels that
there was a dedicated shaver outlet that
said shavers only did you see this I
didn't even see that as a man who shaves
I would have thought that she would have
tuned right into that there's a shaver
outlet shaver is said shavers only at
the airport and at the hotel there was a
shaver only and I was so upset I didn't
bring my shaver well now I have a reason
to go back the toilets deuce flush the
other way but I did not note that
Christie told me that last night when I
was like what's what are some of the
highlights for you she was like flush
good does go the other way well the
reason I didn't note it and still doubt
whether or not it's true is because I
got it - got my wife told me all the
toilets that we used I didn't have a
swirl they were just they were
you're just stuck it was like a trapdoor
a little man
a little man came up and I mean we're
talking about restrooms and sucked it
straight down there every restroom that
you went to and let me tell you brothers
and sisters I went to the restroom a lot
I had a ball just a sermon me past the
plate cuz I need to get some TP
I need it my budget and my TP budgets
running low in the analogy now clean
talking about no clean they were hand
dryer oh the hand rice they didn't have
any paper products I don't even think
they have woods in Australia they must
not yeah think about it did you actually
we did see woods we did but they weren't
having to turn it into toilet paper I
get e petty criminals like to have their
hands blowing on right big blow off
because they're constantly snatching
little insignificant things and you
don't want to rough them up with paper
towels you want air man Dyson is from
Australia that's why Dyson is Australian
for vacuuming isn't that are you sure
that Dyson is from Australia pretty sure
look that up can you verify that I'm
pretty sure man the guy on the
commercials Australian anyway Dyson
everywhere and you know all kinds of
thing the air blades like you put you I
I always have a crisis of conscience
about what I'm thinking if I like them
or not
like I really love a good Dyson
technological advancement but it's tight
quarters for your hands like I felt like
I'm really touching the stuff that
everyone else is touching but they had
different things they didn't just have
the blade and of all they had holes they
had air hole they had air they had air
fins they had it all man week again this
is the same time everywhere we went and
yes we have confirmation that yeah it's
from oh sorry
yep but listen if you're one of the next
30 people to agree what you also can say
we were right Perth the place we died he
that Dyson is from Perth now on the end
and for other side of the con and shout
out to the Perth Ian's
I'm sorry came to the show and
complained about us not going to Perth I
mean I guess we'll have to check it out
next time it's a big country it's on the
other side but we talked about the
restrooms yeah but I could just the one
last thing about the petty criminals
because it to me because you're talking
about sticking your hands and things
like holes and
slits and different things yeah I think
they're so they stick their hands into
the things without knowing it and takes
them constantly picking things out of
each other's pockets so I want to
continue that thing on with the sanitary
sanitation the drying yeah
petty criminals I mean we would at the
beginning of each show we would build
rapport with our with our audience by
talking about how great everything was
because it was just easy to come up with
something and then so we we found
ourselves talking about how clean the
public restrooms were because everywhere
we went
especially in Brisbane when we were like
walking down the Riverwalk and it's just
immaculate everybody's using stuff and
no one's messing anything up like nice
things are staying nice we go into the
public restroom it's nice I mean we were
gushing about it on on talking to Fallon
yeah we're like oh we got to tell we got
it we're gonna we're gonna devote
precious Tonight Show minutes to gushing
about the cleanliness of Australian
public restrooms and that should say it
all yeah as opposed to what would happen
if it was in America which we won't even
rehash it because you can see that on
our little Fallon segment okay so we're
gonna so you you got our our general
impressions we're gonna talk about some
specific things that happen on the trip
in a second but first I want to take a
short break to let you know that your
biscuits is brought to you by this shirt
that I'm wearing right now we sell merch
and you you helped make this possible by
supporting entertainment I've got on the
Dinka ends what do I have on diggin is
sink it sure I've got on the Dinka and
sinking shirt sinking it has a mouth on
the front that says GMM on the tongue it
says Dinkin sinking on the back it's
just one of many t-shirts that you can
find at mythical tot store go over there
and just browse around we also have an
Amazon store it's got some of the same
stuff some different stuff oh man it'll
surprise you oh man it'll surprise you
thanks for supporting Internet tainment
so we went to Melbourne first we had a
friend who was just from the outskirts
of Melbourne he was early building it
up and he was like you know I I always
gush about my hometown and but it just
you know just people kind of roll their
eyes they just don't get it but I think
when you go you'll get it and I do I
think we got it
it's a great place y'all every place we
went is highly recommend going to
Melbourne every place we went is great
but I think the family consents is the
consensus between the two of us and the
consensus between our lives and our kids
is that Melbourne was the best they got
really good food I mean anywhere you if
you trip and fall you'll land in a flat
white which if you've been to Starbucks
like in the past year or so they started
pushing these things called flat whites
which I didn't know what it was I was
just okay Starbucks whatever I'll get
one well that's what that's the main
thing they got down there it's basically
a latte without the foam without the
poem which I was like this is brilliant
more coffee less foam foam sucks if you
ask me and except just a flat little
layer of it and you could anywhere you
fell you'd land in one and it would take
anyway tastes good here and it validated
my my problem your problem my addiction
to coffee well as someone who has not
been drinking coffee and been drinking
mostly tea almost exclusively tea just
cuz it kind of is a coffee messes I'm a
stomach in my skin and stuff I still
like coffee more but you know I'm cursed
I was like I'm not gonna go to this
place and not have the coffee and I mean
it was a combination of having abstained
from coffee
in general so I was getting like my
first latte in months but it was flat
white it was absolutely incredible and
it didn't matter the cost
it didn't matter the level of the place
that you went it was a nice restaurant
had great coffee in a little hole in the
wall had great coffee and it just it is
just it's an abomination what has
happened
I don't know how America got to a play
we're coffee for most people is this
thing that is just dripped into this
glass mug that is you've been so snob a
fight that is on a highwayman and is
sitting there in a diner just burning
and it just poured out for you without
gas hands and like a convenience store
and it's just bitter like there's just
something beautiful that they respect it
so much and they give it to you in the
way that you want it and it doesn't well
again it and we're talking about
prisoners here they didn't invent it
right you know they just said all right
they this is done really well in other
parts of the world I probably stole
their first batch if we're gonna stay
we're gonna steal it we're gonna stole
it they made it better not hard if
you're gonna steal something make it
better that's what you can learn from
most girls don't really steal it go all
the way yeah and then the food in
general I mean at all places but the
first meal the first day and first of
all the adjustment going everybody was
like 14 hour flight 16 hour flight
you're from LA your jet lag going we'll
be okay
your jet lag coming back will be the
worst you've ever experienced listen
we've been back well over a week I've
been we went to New York and now we're
back again that made it worse I am still
out of sorts
yeah I I I cannot sleep at night and
I'll get like nauseous for no reason
yeah because you're seeing the toilet go
the other way
I'm asthma right being hypnotized by
your own feces meat pies everything was
great but we got I mean we didn't get
this until we went to Brisbane but I
think it's everywhere you go to a bar
and you can order chicken parm oh my
gosh and you're not gonna believe
they've taken
they've taken chicken and they've
schnitzels it out they've hammered it
out until it's like as big as I don't
know a human torso yeah it depends on
the human probably child breaded it up
they've made chicken parmesan and you
might be like okay chicken parmesan
okay again but they didn't come up with
it Italy Italia came up with a stole
they stole it from Italia but they will
avoid it better and they serve it in
bars and then you go in there and you
get this giant piece yes perfectly if
you yeah breaded slamdown chicken if you
take it to go they put it in a freaking
what appears to be a pizza box but
that's just for you and listen it isn't
just it doesn't it's not this piece of
meat with a piece of cheese on it and
then slathered with marinara no no no no
no this piece of meat was they had a
thin layer of marinara sauce then a
piece of him the things we're talking
about we devote so much fun to chicken
parm and receptacles and then this is a
piece of cheese that cover the whole
thing and it was just one of like four
different kinds you could get at this
pup they got these things called
laneways which here's my advice when
going to a city that you've never been
to very early on like I'm talking day
one it may be day to sign up for a
walking tour a highly-rated walking tour
if you're in the food make it about food
if you're in the art make it about art
we took a street art walking tour in
Melbourne because they have streets that
are designated it's cool to to put what
some people call graffiti but I call
street art or tagging up there and tag
it but then you kind of it's a way to be
guided for a few hours to then have your
interest piqued about other things that
you can come back to we made the mistake
one time in New York which we've been a
lot but we started doing we did a food
walking tour which was great but we did
it on the last day we were there and it
it actually became very frustrating
because we found a number of things we
wanted to go back to and we didn't get
to do that so that's just a little
practical piece of advice take a walking
tour early but we saw a few of these
streets that were like I mean
everything's really spaced out and what
we learned from the the walking tour was
that the architect who planned it he
just made it really wide and like he
fought tooth and nail to make the
streets as wide as they were he had a
giant horse he had a really fat horse
must have had a really maybe
seven y-yes a seven wide fat horse but
now you can have you can have both lanes
of car streets but then still have
plenty of room in the middle for trains
which you can hop on and off of for free
and I could get anywhere remember what
they call those in common they had a
specific name for what's in a trial
aureum cars or something I am but
basically it was like a San Francisco
trolley so in stark contrast to that you
look down what appears to be like a much
more narrow street which was not playing
by the architect but then as things were
built up they made these narrow streets
which were akin to what you I don't know
what you might see in London well I've
never walked around I have and but it's
about European style so basically these
the streets that you can drive a car
down them but you don't anymore and they
would be like one lane and there's lots
of cobblestone lots of cafes and the
cafes like have their slot like out into
the laneway no car at all I just I've
always I don't know if just feels so
cool well there's like this I had this
thing for nooks and crannies yeah like
I'm really in like when I see like I'm
always want to when I'm looking cranny
man I don't know if it's because I'm so
big and it has to be a big cranny for me
to get into it but if I can get myself
into a cranny I will look it right up
you would not believe it and and so I I
I don't know what really is but when you
get in there I'm like that must have
been a cranny I absolutely love getting
into these small places that's one of
the reasons that New York is one of
favorite places on earth because you can
walk and then you look down there
there's a freaking door down there and
it looks like there's people down there
having fun and there's people above them
and that they're having fun you know
everybody's doing something and it's
nooks and crannies man they almost
called New York that sometimes I'll be
like yeah I'll be in nook and cranny
land and I'll be like where's red and I
won't see anywhere now I'll backtrack a
block or two and I'll just see him
wedged in what I'm canal cranny yeah
sometimes you have to lose - give me a
hey I'm break out the lube the cranny
Lube right I keep I keep a I keep a tube
a cranny lube in my back I'm mucked up
here you got a you got a loo
me out of this Cranbourne a big man
likes crannies you got to have Lube on
hand look look lube is it cranny Lube or
nook little they're both it's kind of
like the tip size of a Twix no it's like
left and right twigs we sell both at
mythical dot store the sleeve and cranny
little secret and they reset up this
hallmark anything where they're
competing against each other looking
blue versus cranny Lou your favorite is
no clue but my favorite is cranny loop
not to be confused with granny Lube
which is something we're not good at you
yeah but you just did
we went and then we we booked a day trip
out of town we went on the great ocean
road which by the way they stole from us
the PCH highway along the the western
coast of the United States yes that's
what the story is they stole that and
put it along their coast which is
absolutely beautiful he's not kidding
because we went on a tour and the guy
said kid about Annie the guy that came
up with the idea for the great ocean
road had recently visited California and
saw the Pacific Coast Highway yeah and
he saw appreciation was like I'm gonna
do that no twelve apostles is like the
destination but it it takes from
Melbourne you're going further around
South I think I got my cardinal
directions correct but who cares
go on West three hours you'll get a
twelve apostles which um they're not
twelve Oh but basically it's giant rock
rock formations that used to be a part
of a some monolithic cliff that began to
be eroded down and then there are these
pillars that we were told that at no
time were there twelve but because there
were twelve apostles it was a cool thing
to say twelve apostles but I think
there's only six or seven at this point
depending on how you define one and
they've like falling down like a couple
of them are falling down in the past
like 23 years anyway actually I follow a
couple of it's it's a beautiful well I
I've been following even before I knew
we were gonna go I've always loved the
idea of Australia and I follow a couple
of Instagram accounts one is basically
dedicated all this stuff on the great
ocean road and so I've seen this on
Instagram millions of times I got to go
and and check this out and so we went on
this tour oh you're welcome
with yeah you set this up thank you for
saying that
we said we went on this tour with
everybody and then we were on a bus with
you know 20 other I don't know 15 to 20
other people
I'll apologize for that part of it you
told me that we were gonna be alone I
thought we were gonna be alone but we're
on a bus with too many people too much
condensation in that bus and that's why
I was late to the bus man I was late to
the bus because you had told me it's
just us and so I was like I got
something that McCraney I gotta get out
real fast I had to take a dump with what
another way of saying that and and and
then but you know you know it's like I
got it first of all that's a misuse of
the term cranny like all of that all all
the collateral everything we built like
we spent all this time building up this
great thing about nooks and crannies it
was like it was a high point in a
podcast I'm sorry like I just found
myself thinking you know what we'll edit
it out I thought if this podcast sucks
from here on out it'll be fine because
of what we built from nothing with this
nook and cranny thing and then you
decimate it are you thinking about
butthole you miss a cried it yeah sorry
you miss supply it has nothing to do
with that I had to defecate sorry I
should have just said I had to use the
restroom but I wanted to give you a
sense of time well anyway we get to the
12 apostles and let me tell you that's
why I was late to the buses it was what
it was worth suffering in the back of
this bus I mean literally you and I were
the last ones long cuz I was waiting for
you I I said in the last row in a
smaller seat or I was also lower but it
doesn't matter because I'm kind of like
a giraffe but it was worth it because it
was so beautiful
and let me tell you we had a good time I
had a great time Christie my wonderful
wife had a great time it was that we had
a great time together I mean we just
bonded it was amazing we were taking
photos with our family and it was it was
just sound like you're setting up a
juxtaposition was a milestone event for
in my relationship with my wife is just
a bright shining beacon of of what our
relationship that's what we aspire for
it to be
you're saying this because you know that
my wife and I had a misunderstanding
while on the tour yeah it got it got
pretty heated I honestly do not remember
exactly what the subject of the argument
was that just made it worse
well no didn't learn your lesson oh I
don't know what you did but I know you
did something wrong if she was mad no it
it was I don't remember exactly what I
said but I said something that she took
as me being critical and she was like
you don't have to you don't have to
parent me or something like that I think
it was related to the taking of photo no
that was so no see we had an initial
conversation oh that was about something
I hadn't like corrected her about and
she got mad at me and then I asked
someone to take a photo it was your
fault no you were already fine now that
I think about it it was your freakin
fault because I had made up
oh you know what I told her you know
what I told her right before you did you
you did that I told her I said I am NOT
going to say one judgmental or critical
thing for the rest of this trip and then
you catch up with us and I'm like kids
gather around
can somebody take our photo in front of
the apostles it's so beautiful and then
and then she was like I'll do it
she and I gave her my phone she gets up
there to take the photo and here's what
I here's honestly what I'm thinking at
the time I'm like link it's super
particular about photos and I know
exactly what you want in your photo I
know how you want you the Headroom in
the composition you want this to be a
special moment yeah so she's volunteered
to take and again it was on this is yeah
this is why it's part of it is a problem
and I have contributed it to contributed
to it in our marriage but what this is
why this is my fault
no cuz I said he's not gonna like that
and it was like reaching for the phone
to take the picture and she looked at me
and just she may have given me the bird
I can't remember exactly what happened
but if she got so mad and she just
walked off it was a it was this it was
the straw that broke the camel's because
I just said that was a way to do it
anymore
and then you set me up man you set me
hold on did you guys do it was it a
setup for real
no it wasn't so I'm sitting there
chasing after her thinking I've got to
make this right and this is when you
know Christy says that she actually told
us later that she could see other
couples was like she was in a place
where she could see couples go past us
and then get close to you guys yeah
because we were all walking back at this
point and Jesse and I were arguing and
it was like I was trying to apologize
but then I got mad because she wouldn't
accept my words like mad at each other
and people like see us arguing and then
they started talking about us and you
could hear the things that there yeah
and then they would pass Christy and she
would hear man they really upset at each
other but the ironic thing is or the
beautiful thing is that it was a great
picture that we got great pictures and
my wife posted to her Instagram and
Twitter or at least her Instagram she
posted a picture of us a family picture
and she was like you know life hacker
tip or the day or whatever she said
always remember no matter what you feel
like or even if you're in the middle of
a fight with your husband
smile in your picture so you can look
back on this memory and not remember the
argument or whatever it was much more
eloquent than what I just said so she
took this picture she like smiled this
beautiful smile for the picture and then
herself as soon as the picture had been
taken she was just back to well it's
funny that you said ironically and you
were telling I do think but also I
thought you were gonna say ironically
the picture she took was a good picture
oh well I was happy with the picture
yeah oh good yes yeah I have a problem
man we actually continued to work
through that throughout the trip and in
it happened good thing that there was
like another eight hours in the trip no
no I mean that long I mean the trip oh
hey case you three weeks because it is
something as she has pointed out
multiple times it's something that comes
out while on vacation there's a special
type of you know it's just the
ingredients for family conflict wait
what is it me well first of all they're
right from the beginning of the trip
because we see we I have travel anxiety
in a way that she doesn't so I'm the one
who I'm like the quintessential dad who
gets the family to the airport 14 hours
early you know what I'm saying
like I'm like get up everybody we gotta
get there we're flying on Wednesday you
know I I'm I have this anxiety and I'm
not typically an anxious person when it
comes to a lot of things but I'm I get
anxious about the parts of a trip that I
feel that I actually have control over
so in other words as soon as I get
through security my heart rate goes way
down because I don't care I'm not
nervous about flying because it's in
somebody else's hands if we're gonna if
we're gonna bring in to crash is but I
do have the power to get to the airport
to make the right decisions about where
we're gonna park or if right now is uber
right this is understandable but how is
this the problem it's a problem because
she does not exhibit any sense of
urgency or or concern or anxiety at all
about these things and so what we kind
of landed on is so what I'm doing is I
start getting I get mad at her and she
gets mad at me for caring and I get mad
at her for not caring about these things
and it just starts this tension that
builds so will you assume that she cares
none just because she's not at a height
that this like frantic level that you
are well I tell her and you start to
what mean you have talked about this
before when we when we work with people
that we haven't worked with before and
we don't sometimes we might be might be
somebody who's directing us or doing
something and it's just like they don't
seem to
understand the gravity of this and the
way that we do and it's not necessarily
true it's just some people don't express
your anxiety in the same way me and you
know when we were anxious about
something so yes it isn't that she
doesn't care anyway I don't want to get
into a counseling situation but we
actually made late we made some progress
because what I communicated to her is
that okay listen I can't I've got to
learn to not be critical and to and to
point things out and be judgmental and
let this tension build and what she
agreed to is to just X not let it feel
like it's all my responsibility for all
these things and for her to kind of go
along for the ride but she's actually
going to she sees that I have to signal
that I am concerned about these things
and just a just an acknowledgment that I
am concerned about getting to the
airport on time or packing right before
the last minute that's enough to put me
at ease is just how does that look like
to the to the picture though I know I'm
saying in general I can be critical but
it starts when we travel like Oh tension
is the the tension is increased you're
on the edge and so now you're on the
edge and so any little thing like that
will just set one of us off yeah but we
get but we got through it and by the
time I mean first of all and they both
feel like you were parenting her as how
she puts it like if it's like don't take
a picture that way or we got to get to
the airport
I get yes what can I do to help well
next time you sense that that is
happening I didn't sense and II don't
ask either one of us I didn't do
anything sir man just do a selfie or get
a stranger get a strange get a stranger
ask a stranger to take take your photo
then we went to Sydney and met I mean we
check in a hotel and then we walk a
block and we're like we're in the middle
of a furry convention photoshoot yeah
which it was on our Instagram well let's
explain how this happened because first
of all it was the most controversial
Instagram photo ever posted to the
rhettandlink account based on the number
of the amount of debate in the in the in
the comment section now let we first
walk
we walked up to the fountain at the
nearest park which is what was strolling
around and everybody is in full
head-to-toe mascot wear and wear I mean
we a medium is like I've heard of
furries I saw an episode of CSI the
original mm-hmm way back in the day
featuring furries one of which I think
was dead and it was it was weird but I
never experienced furries well in person
and you might have been able to decipher
this based on the look in my face look
on my face in the photo I know about the
I kind of know about wrap that yeah the
reputation that furries have built and
which is that there's just some stuff
there's some stuff that goes on I mean
you can look at the Wikipedia you can
look at the controversy side of freedom
and on the Wikipedia page I'm not gonna
go into the details I'm not validating
that I'm not confirming that I'm not
denying that I don't know anything about
it but I knew about the reputation in
some circles you're also not condemning
it that's I'm I don't again I don't know
if it's a if it's a founded reputation I
don't know anything about it but I'm
saying that as we were there I was like
this is this will be funny people will
think that it's funny and something and
it will start some comments if we take a
picture with first and I'm like as
opposed to cool people in full bodysuits
fur and I think a lot of people on our
Instagram account thought that we were
just completely clueless had no idea
what we were doing it I'm not completely
clueless but you know but I'll let me
take it right now as a scene but I lots
of those were at a time lots of those
furries were mythical beasts I mean
literally in one sense which is enough
for me man I'm in uh-huh well I'm in I'm
not in I mean I don't have a costume I
mean I do I will say that I did have one
I think she was a squirrel or something
I don't know what she was but she was
with her husband and she got a lower
husband was not in a suit he was the
photographer well 8:4 talk she got a
little fresh with me and I hope I
haven't used that term in a long time so
maybe you're not familiar with it all
I'm saying is that I was taking a
picture with her and she
really she got locked on like a body
like I was a I was a pole that she was
holding on to in a tornado and three
that contained her nuts yeah it was
and she really she got her leg up into a
space is she really latched on but I
think I done to my cranny not gosh I
shouldn't do that
it was my look actually but it was she
put her knee in my nook and I was
uncoupled it's not say she let's say the
squirrel does cuz I think yeah because
it was a squirrel I didn't mind maybe
that's the whole thing maybe that's
that's not your three that's what it is
okay we're just animals who cares who
cares if my wife puts her knee in your
nook she's just a squirt as long as the
composition is good and you don't parent
me know how to take the photo properly I
think this is a win-win so we got some
we got some good traction on the
Instagram which is really all that
matters mission accomplished you guys
fell for it yeah you fell for it yeah
it's great
Sydney is different than Melvin should
see my suit yeah link is now a furry
you'll never know which one he is though
Sydney's different than Melbourne it's a
little bit bigger not a lot bigger but
it is more people smoke absolutely
absolutely
it's a beautiful place I mean you know
you've got they got this thing called
the Opera House oh yeah you know about
that I actually thought it was really
cool when I saw it I was like whoa it's
just an amazing architecture it's
beautiful the bridge is beautiful we'll
talk about the bridge in a second the
whole harbor the bay there it's it is
one of the most beautiful places that
I've ever been took a real boring
walking tour right when we got there so
it doesn't always work out I think that
the the density in of Melbourne and just
the fact that every single experience we
had was so great there and where while
in Sydney it was kind of it was a little
bit more hit or miss it was kind of the
difference I don't know it was a little
more New York and I absolutely loved New
York but it can feel a little bit like
and I guess la is the same way it just
kind of feels like there's so much here
I really don't know exactly was it it
wasn't as distinct it was right
everything is there kind of a thing yes
but we we just
I did to do the bridge climb which well
this was Jenna's thing cuz like I was
the one making all the things saying we
should do this we should do that and
Jenna kept bringing up this bridge climb
and I kept saying my house I don't know
I'm cool with it
I mean I knew Christy would not want to
do that so like I wasn't I wasn't
pushing it but like every time I turn
around she was she mentioned that bridge
climb and then we finally did it and I'm
I'm glad we did oh it was a highlight
Christy didn't do it but um at one point
on the bridge climb you the guys taking
photos all along but at one point they
he says now I'm gonna take a little
video I said well me and the kids got
together and they we took a little video
because they said we put it on Facebook
because they like to promote the bridge
climb I think and we said we gave
Christian message we were just like I
got the kids who say hey mom miss you
wish you were here and I'm like yeah
this I bet this is gonna get me laid
that's what I was thinking oh cool
because that's my idea you know it's
like we're up here having the time of
our lives but we're we're all we love
you and we're only thinking about you
that's what it takes for you I've gotta
climb to a freakin bridge and make a
video no but it but it helps you know
you gotta always be thinking about it
did it work yeah congratulations I was
like hey I got let me show you the
photos we took today up here's a little
video from the family I was it was my
idea I was really thinking about you
yeah really setting the standard pretty
I wanted to be with you you just want
you to know at the height if she begins
to it's a literal height of Sydney I was
only thinking about you just word to the
wise though you don't want to
necessarily set those expectations and
set that standard that in order for
there to be on a scale something
business time you have got to do some
sort of incredible display of your your
love the bars got to come back down yeah
yeah yeah along with me that's the
bridge climb highly recommended though
absolutely fascinating in the way that
they have
the engineering degrees that we still
have we don't use there's a part of us
that gets into this type of thing the
system that they have established that
gets you on to this bridge climb and the
way that everything is hooked to your
body on this onesie with all these hooks
and then you hook into this thing and
you're literally attached to this wire
the entire time and you the entire time
that you go all the way up to the top of
the bridge okay all the way back down we
should clarify that it's it's one huge
art it is an art it is the the longest
single arc suspension bridge I don't
know in the world whatever the type of
bridge that it is is the longest like
single span so at a certain point you're
literally walking along that top part
like that the tallest point on the
bridge and we did the Twilight so we saw
the sunset the sunset at the peak of the
bridge in crab solutely incredible now
one of the things I saw when we got to
the place was that you know this is an
operation that has been they've been
doing this for a while and they've got
it's a really incredible operation when
you walk in and there's all these photo
as photos popping up on the screens of
all the celebrities who have been on the
bridge and so in a dick combat you've
got Will Ferrell and basically almost
every actor or athlete that you can
think of has Benedict Cumberbatch been
on this bridge and taking a picture now
this is one of those situations where I
show up and I see all these pictures and
I'm like okay this is my ego my ego sets
in a little bit and I'm like well they
know that they know they got two
world-class youtubers up in the house
right now and I and I want to be like
well you know what will it take for us
to get our picture up there in the in
the Will Ferrell rotation right but of
course you can't be the one that says
anything about it
and I'm not gonna like go tell Jenna to
say something to him so I just kind of
didn't say anything at all
and but that was why we didn't we
weren't next to each other we had like
our families kind of in between us or at
least a couple of kids in between us
because you because once you pick an
order that you're gonna latch on and go
on the route you can't change order
because you're literally latched in an
order right and so but I was like on the
off chance that at some point someone
who works at bridge climb might happen
to he figures out oh those guys are on
YouTube let's take a picture of the two
of us together and that's where that
picture of us in the onesies together
came from and listen I haven't been back
to bridge slam I don't know if you guys
have put us in the rotation you don't
have to I mean yes I'm happy but I'm
happy as I am I don't I don't need I
don't need to be in the in the rotation
to feel it to feel validated high
altitude validation I mean I've got
cranny loop I don't I don't need like I
don't need your system as I've already
established I got I got what I came for
exactly and my wife nothing to do with a
screen my wife went with me hmm
also my youngest son got sick remember
that part yeah like coming down sudden I
realized every time he stopped he just
kneel
he just started he'd take a knee and why
is Shepherd taking a knee and every time
we stop I thought he's queasy is it
because we're climbing we were high up
it was scary at first but he's not you
know he's not he doesn't that's not his
disposition he's not one to be shaken in
that way so I was like hopefully this is
not something worse it turns out it was
something worse and that's why he was
actually sick and that's why I had to
stay home with him the next day yeah you
guys took the trix day we did another
day trip out to the Blue Mountains it
was freaking beautiful out there there's
like these like vertical ravines and you
can go on all these different I don't
build it up too much I didn't get to go
to make a serious and patient devices
that take you on these amazing
beautification and beautiful scenic
routes it's pretty awesome and it wasn't
that great was it it was great it was so
great Rhett and then it wasn't like a
highlight of the trip it was a highlight
man I mean at one point I'll tell you
this we went into this they call it a
cultural presentation but it was mr.
cultural it was it was a Aboriginal
information session / dramatization
there's a lot of is Asians and and they
talked about well they put on this
dramatization where the guy he reenacted
the discovery of the didgeridoo like
wind flowing through a hollow log that
made a noise and then he picked it up
and started learning how to play it and
then this guy that's how it happened
that's I mean that's what they say
legend has it
legend has it and then he starts playing
a didgeridoo in this small little
theatre and it was amazing man like I
didn't anticipate that watching a guy
masterfully play the didgeridoo 11 feet
in front of me could bring me to verge
of tears but it did it's in him that way
it's amazing and in the way that he they
developed ways to mimic different
wildlife in the outback where the
didgeridoo with the didgeridoo talked
about all different types of birds and
all types of stuff man it was it was it
was amazing and artful and really cool
but it wasn't it wasn't a canvas I would
not have missed it if I were me were you
but you did miss it and then after that
I want Shepard watch Cartoon Network all
day and he literally watched the same
episode of some show four times we went
to a while I miss it was a camp mystic
sanctuary and you could feed kangaroos
just walk up to him and feed him which
you can also do at Disney World but
don't worry yeah you can do that at
Disney where they can do that in Florida
that's right that's where I'll do it I
was at point-blank range with some
koalas and they smell funny
and then like how like we're like a musk
like a eucalyptus Musk kind of situation
actually sounds like a great fragrance
but it is not that's them that's what
I'm gonna start adding that to granny
loop you could pay extra to feed the
koalas
and you and the Kangaroos which we did
and then you go into the next section
and there's like wombats which are like
got awfully huge gerbils I'm talking
about like a pig sized guinea pig really
cute gerbil based on the pictures of
course I haven't seen them in person
mixed with like a beaver in the face a
little bit and there's signs everywhere
we bite you look any direction you look
there's a sign it says we bite do not
feed the wombats let me give you my
perspective on this because I get a text
from my wife with a picture of my son
holding his hand up and it says lot got
bit by wombat lock tried to feed the
wombat turns out they bite who would
have known aggressively I didn't see it
happen but I mean it was but I mean I
saw blood like I saw evidence of an
altercation it drew blood like I'm
talking about on the path I'm talking
about I didn't know I was like I just I
walk up the wombat station and I see
blood don't see Locke and I'm like and
then I start looking for looking for
Locke because he's the best candidate
for that yeah he had a couple of
accident I mean you're feeding kangaroos
then there's a wombat you know you don't
look at signs okay whatever I keep
throwing your family under the bus you
mainly you and your son but I got a
story I'll throw a Lando under the bus
in a little bit because we haven't even
gotten to Fiji I mean this is eg yeah
Fiji we should move to that but so we
did our shows we we patched up the kids
who needed patching up Locke namely yeah
and we left Australia thinking we will
come back I mean it's just it's like the
greatest place on earth as far as we're
concerned I'm really interested in going
into the outback like I want to do like
an off-roading thing yeah well I want to
do I want it also race with Hamish and
Andy we'll see who can get across the
continent first well of course we'll
cheat well as we ain't got time to
actually do it they're gonna
without a doubt but yeah I'll say that
we went in the peak of winter which
first of all is really mild in Australia
at least where we were not a the weather
was incredible
I would like to go back in the summer
last people said go back in the summer
so we can like experience the beaches in
the way that they are intended to be
experienced but I'm gonna say that I've
been to some incredible places it was
also the fact that we got to experience
multiple cities and we got to be there
for an extended period yeah that helps
but I gotta say that it is my favorite
vacation favorite vacation and favorite
place that I've ever visited
it was and I haven't been a whole lot of
places but it right now on my list
Australia is my favorite place on earth
it was my favorite place and I think it
was my favorite trip because we did such
intense sight scene in I mean we only
spent one day in Brisbane that's where
we got to chicken parm and did the show
family didn't come then we flew back to
Sydney where they were but it was
intense active site scene and just out
on its own would have just been
exhausting so the fact that we had five
full days in Fiji oh man that would that
just really that was I love the
arrangement of going hard for
sightseeing and then going light yes and
with with just on the beach just sprawl
out and let it happen to you and let
Fiji happen to you and you know since
you encouraged me to thank you for you
know the excursions of which one I
didn't get to go on the this thank you
for choosing this the stopping and the
in Fiji brilliant and and picking the
specific place Rhett was Douglas that
was based on always been obsessed with
Island Islands are my there's like a
long awkward pause in our life he's
gonna he's probably gonna bring up an
island well the funny thing is is now
I'm beginning to see I'm really into
nooks and crannies and I'm really into
islands and I got to experience both is
there an islet island give all over you
nooks and crannies because that would be
absolutely
we flew into Fiji on the mainland and
then we took a what they call a
speedboat just a really fast boat they
still took 30 minutes to go it was dark
so it's hard to tell exactly what we
passed some islands and then we went to
the island called castaway island which
is basic I don't know if that's the
proper name of the island but it's the
name of the resort on the island which
is the only resort on the island which
at low tide just to give you an idea how
big the island is you could hike all the
way around the island in an hour so it's
pretty small it's the only resort on the
island and there's like 60 individual
huts where you can stay that's all
that's the extent when we were planning
this trip the ice first of all you know
Fiji has over 300 islands and I've
always wanted to stay on an island that
small I felt like I was stranded right
you think it might be the the the huts
on stilts that are over the ocean water
but that's like Bora Bora that's a
defeat there well there are so we did
pass a few there's some but that's not
really what it's known for but our the
travel agent that we were using actually
was like well you guys have got kids you
probably should do a resort on the
mainland you know cuz they're gonna get
bored or whatever and I was like listen
I don't know if we're ever gonna go back
to this place I want to do I don't care
how bored the kids get I want to live
like Robinson Caruso on an island that I
can walk around and that's why we chose
this this place and so the boat pulls up
to the island and the guy is like it's
gonna be a wet landing and we're like
hahahaha and then we realized there's no
dock the boat and we had all our luggage
the boat just pulls up to the sandy
beach yeah like two foot of water and we
have to literally take our shoes off and
roll our jeans up and walk into the
ocean to get onto the island because
there was not a dock I mean that's how
Island this island is but there's
resorts on all of these little islands
because they're all protected by a
Barrier Reef from huge surf so there's
not surf crashing on any of these
beaches it's like
totally swimmable just mild it still got
windy but there wasn't the waves
crashing on on the beaches ever
especially on the side of the island
where we were luxuriating mm-hmm
I mean I've never I've never it's just
the best place I've ever stayed man well
it's like you stay in this hot you see
these wall cars like I've owned islands
but I'd like to see these postcards or
these pictures on the internet and I'm
just like I mean we've been to Hawaii
and Hawaii is incredible and beautiful
yeah but at least the parts that we went
to it wasn't like that picturesque like
Beach with the palm trees and the
hammock but that's what this was it was
like that it wasn't just palm trees
there were all types of trees that grew
right up to the beach and then the huts
were like in there it was just really
amazing it was perfect man it's what
everything I hope for so then I'm like
I'm sitting on my lounge chair I got my
little drink from the bar that I just
walked down there to and then I'm in the
shade cuz I don't like to sit in the Sun
and I'm like you know I'm getting kind
of cold oh my god I'm just gonna go out
there on the sand and I'm just gonna
splay out and I'm just gonna get warm
I'll come right back to my seat next
thing I know I'm plastered all over
Instagram shout-out to the red AMC
Instagram account that's mine and
shout-out to link LaMotte who does not
activate his Instagram account ever and
that's why I put him on my Instagram
although I do tag your account you're
welcome thank you so I mean how am I
supposed to put stuff I'm on Instagram
account if I'm sleeping it's like I'm
sleeping
yeah so I've got better things to do
than social media eyes I have noticed
that link strikes a very particular pose
when sleeping while traveling usually
it's the mouth open and I like to get
pictures of that posted on my Instagram
but then when I saw him splayed out on
the beach I was like this is a whole new
thing I'm gonna make this into it like
an artistic photo set did you know I was
asleep at first yeah either that or dead
yeah cuz I bet they're not moved in in
minutes definitely it was a little odd I
mean I've seen the photos that you took
and there were plural yeah I basically
just moved I didn't really some odd and
was taking pictures and of course my
wife and your wife were watching this
whole thing happen and then I use the
wife okay interesting tidbit about this
place no TVs no internet so it was
really legitimately off the grid now
there was internet at the like the
office area so you could go out to like
this restaurant and get on internet but
internet was like slow and not reliable
as is evidenced by the fact that it took
me like 30 minutes to post that photo
set but I just sat there waiting for it
to happen because I knew that it was
gonna weren't making a lot of people
happy oh yeah totally worth it totally
worth it thank you thank you for posing
thank you it was a pleasure to be your
muse once again and we also because you
need to tell that story about Lando but
we went to now it's called castaway
island in a lot of people a lot of
travel agents including the one that we
used incorrectly think that the island
that we stayed on is the island where
they filled them film the movie castaway
well starring Tom Hanks is it true first
of all they do have supposedly the
paddle that Tom Hanks used on his raft
in the bar in the restaurant but it's
just like up there is this Tom Hanks
paddle from castaway mm and if kids act
up or get too rambunctious they take it
down and they paddled right yeah well
actually Tom Hanks he come he shows up
and he does it he lives in a hut not you
can actually see the real castaway
island the mode Ricky they call it or
mono Ricky it's got two different names
it's about 10 miles from the island that
we stayed at and you can see it
basically as you're on the beach right
there in front of the huts that we were
staying in unless you're sleeping and we
had signed up to take a boat trip to the
island for a day very and this that was
super cool because there's not we watch
this movie with our kids this year
because we knew we were gonna get
there's nothing on that island I mean
you could probably I I don't know you
can't hike around that Island with the
way that the the water hits the beach it
is smaller than the eyes we stayed on
probably half the size but it's taller
yes
and III really couldn't tell there's the
scene where he tries to end his life at
the top of the island I really couldn't
make the connection with the landscape
that that was there was a shot there was
a couple of places that looked like
Canada's but the main thing that we were
struck by by was so the first thing we
did we get on the island and first of
all the the Fiji attitude towards
everything is kind of like I'm not gonna
give you any warnings about things I'm
not gonna tell you guys what you can't
do there are no rules then we just these
guys just took us on a boat to this
island we're the only people on the
island and the kids just immediately
we're all wearing like water shoes you
know like Reef shoes and because we are
cool and they just yeah just as a
fashion statement they just start hiking
up the island and we're just going
through the palm trees and then and then
going up into the woods and then up to
the top of the island as far as we could
get but then we we came back down and
got that shout out to the red link
Instagram we got the we were like let's
come up with a post that we can do
because they've got like to help me all
in the sand you know yeah I think we may
have implied with the photo that we
arranged the coconuts to spell help me
full disclosure
ear biscuit ear because you're an
insider we found it that way
they do that that's just part of the
thing and also the volleyball is
something they give you when you go on
the tour it's something that Spalding
sells you could go online we could
Wilson tells it Wilson because if
spotting sold it that would kind of the
whole thing I was what if you got the
generic Wilson it doesn't work quite as
well does it no I wonder if Wilson paid
for that I don't know it's a different
time anyway we tweeted and we
instagrammed at Tom Hanks because he's
like you know he's a social media guy he
signs everything with Hanks and then he
responded not he responded not
to finish that sentence no he didn't
respond yeah
he did not respond or he responded nah
I'm just I'm using mm like mm terms well
if he would have responded with not I
would have been very happy not when we
left the island on the way back he said
you want to go snorkeling they took us a
special place to go snorkeling and I had
what I had almost an existential
experience snorkeling over this reef in
like pristine waters Christie told me
later that she was so moved
emotionally by how great the snorkeling
was that she started crying inside of
her snorkel and let me just say you know
I am tears of joy I am so happy that you
both that you both enjoyed the
snorkeling to such a degree like like us
we had never snorkel in such pristine
water like with elevation changes like
that but the interesting thing was you
know like I snored I had a really great
snorkeling experience in Hawaii where
there were there were like large sea
turtles and big fish and it was like it
was awesome you cried in your scuba and
so but and this was great in fact I
think that the coral side of it and like
the vastness and the freedom and the
fact that we were the only ones there
yeah all made it incredible and I
absolutely loved it I have a little bit
of a complaint with my beard it's like I
don't get a good seal so I can't stay
down as long whatever but you guys were
so into it that out there was a part of
me that was like what am what am I
missing like your wife came up and said
she'd been crying and then we're like
where is link and you were just gone
like you were a couple of hundred yards
away from the boat just continuing on in
one line and I was like what is
happening did you think you think I was
never coming back
well that I was about to call my Aquaman
I thought okay I thought what had
happened was you talked about how you
have a little bit of a phobia with the
water and like going and holding your
breath and going under neck
and I thought that you were like dealing
with like a personal fear in your life
I'm gonna go as far away from the boat
as possible as like a personal exercise
and that's why I was like look at look
at him go I was like look at him go he's
like he's deep he's dealing with his
phobia and he's so far like weak if he
gets pulled under by a shark or we can't
help him we're so far from him but he
doesn't care because he's overcoming his
fear but knowing you were just enjoying
yourself right I was really just
enjoying myself but I did decide that I
think to fully conquer my fear of being
underwater I'd like to get I'd like to
do scuba yeah
so that snorkeling experience was
amazing it was a highlight of my entire
life
because for the first time I was I was
introduced into perfect conditions
another world so it was a first for me
in that way in sharp contrast to the two
days before where we signed up for a
four first snork I can't speak anymore
let's just end it when we signed up for
our first snorkelling expedition we had
to take the wind was up and we went to
the outer reef yeah very rough to get
out there and then we started jumping
out of the boat and I'm concerned about
Lando because this is the first time
he's snorkeled not not ever but on this
trip well and these conditions I mean as
somebody who I feel really confident in
the water like I was not confident about
that many people getting out of that
boat in those conditions like I was
really uneasy because it was super wavy
I as soon as the boats stopped
I started getting seasick because it was
sort of like a side wobble kind of thing
happening and then when I got into the
water I got even more seasick because it
was the waves were that high so I was
like I don't know how this is gonna go
for the kids half of us jumped out and
then they told us all to scramble back
into the boat because we had to go to a
different place so there was a little
bit of panic at the beginning we get
back in and then the instructor
reiterates the instructions and I'm
sitting beside Lando I'm like Lando I'm
gonna jump in
you're gonna jump into me and we're
gonna snorkel together and mom's gonna
come with us and then we're gonna follow
the group and do what they say we're
gonna all stay together because he had
this nervous look on his face especially
having jumped in and having immediately
come back in the boat scramble back in
and the instructors saying okay so
remember the hand signals thumbs up
means everything's okay stay with the
group so you can give the thumbs-up if
you're cool but if you want to come back
to the boat just wave just wave like
you're waving goodbye we jump in the in
the ocean again and Lando jumps to me
and I guess it's look on his face and
he's like in pain and then I actually
start getting bit on the leg it turns
out it's like ocean fleas I think is
what they're koushin lice is were they
koushin I don't know boy that sounds
Pleasant doesn't it I'm gonna have those
for the rest of my life now no but I
think it's a little jellyfish or
something I don't know they bite you and
it does hurt and he was particularly
sensitive to it was was being bit more
and he got upset and Lando I mean he's
he's eight he when he gets upset
sometimes he goes full throttle upset
and he starts just saying I gotta get
out of here and I'm like trying to calm
him down trying to calm down and then
I'm like right in his face and I'm at
land oh you're gonna be okay and I'm
like rubbing his leg where he got bitten
I'm like it's gonna be fine
they'll stop you get used to it just
start swimming with us I'm like trying
to talk him talk him back into being
calm and then all of a sudden he's like
he basic I could just see the look on
his face he just made the decision he
was like screw you dad I am not staying
in this ocean he didn't say that out
loud but then he turned toward the boat
and he just started waving and yelling
goodbye like what it's like he thinks
his life is ending he certainly was
acting like his life was ending but he
thought the instructor was saying if you
want to get back in the boat wave
goodbye which to him also meant scream
repeatedly because you're not yet
because it's over for you you're never
getting back in the boat I've enjoyed it
while I've been here goodbye
everyone I love goodbye to Australian
the rest of the world I'm going down
with the ocean lice I saw this from a
distance but thing you couldn't hear the
goodbye but I saw the waving I was like
screaming Oh Christie comes over there
she did he did the exact same thing to
her she couldn't talk him now but then
we we teamed up and we did and we kept
we kept turning to the guy when I given
him the thumbs up like we calmed him
down you know what I said and then lo
and behold he snorkeled with us for the
for the rest of the duration of that
excursion which wasn't that long cuz it
was choppy but he didn't go back in the
back of the boat and I was and I was
like you know what land oh I'm so proud
of you you did it buddy you had courage
and you overcame your fear and then two
days later I overcame my fear and I swam
like Aquaman there's a growth experience
for my entire family and that in that
but that first trip was not there was
nothing to see man there was really
there was really nothing there's nothing
to see kind of cloudy it was a little
too deep except everyone else watching
Lando I think is I think that's the only
thing that's aw
all in all a tremendous yeah I agree I
think I think the combination the
one-two punch of Australia and in
luxurious Fiji was just was just a
brilliant combo I mean taking the
longest vacation we've ever taken after
not taking one for free a proper one for
years I feel like it feels good man I'm
so glad we did it our kids don't they
don't know how to appreciate it yeah you
kind of have to do let's not even get in
forget I even said that well you know
because in one sense we don't appreciate
it either no I mean the thing is I
appreciate it no no yeah you do but what
I'm saying is that but I don't think
about what happened with like think
about what happened with the feet the
Fiji trip think about how excited think
about it how excited we were when we got
off that boat and they like escorted us
to that to that table and gave us are
drinking gave us our food and you had
that like fish curry the very first meat
I was
he and I was like and I McCain I told
you I was like this is the best this is
the best place I've ever been like yeah
but my expectations were so high and we
talked about this we talked we talked
about this on a previous podcast about
you have to you can't have these
expectations but right or wrong by the
last day come ray go kind of ready to go
home ray go home it was a combination
the fact that it was a small place and
that you basically were eating at the
same place over and over again
I just miss Jade so much man I had to I
literally had to take her she's my the
wallpaper on my phone she's my
screensaver I literally had to take her
off my phone I couldn't bear it all
right was she happy to see you yeah I
think so
you sure she didn't forget you know I
don't know I saw the way she was looking
at you the other day and it seemed like
suspicious it seemed like it was a new
it was a new man anyway
highly recommended if you're gonna do
that trip I definitely recommend going
to Australia we're gonna go back at some
point now I don't know when that's gonna
happen people a lot of people ask things
like well you guys seem to kind of
indicate that you were gonna go back
next year don't we didn't say we're
gonna go back next year we don't know
what we're gonna do just just know that
we don't keep anything we don't keep
anything from you if we're going to do
something as soon as the plans are
something that you can rely on we let
you know so I don't know when we'll be
back and I don't know exactly what
cities will go to but we have such a
good time we have every intention to
return in the meantime use hash tag ear
biscuits to continue the conversation
with us and try to prioritize I know you
do a good job of this for the most part
just to have continued the conversation
on Twitter so let's do that hashtag
ear biscuits and also share this episode
with someone who has yet to listen to an
episode of your biscuits that that makes
it it makes a big deal
maybe somebody I'm gonna make a big deal
out of maybe somebody who likes to
travel maybe somebody who's been
Australia maybe in Australian maybe a
Fijian maybe somebody who's always
thought about how much they like nooks
and crannies our Islands there's a lots
of reasons that you could share this
particular episode thank you for doing
that
once we get you next week
[Music]